Brian I want to get to you I've known
you for quite a long time because this
gentleman started acting in bits on our
late-night show back in the 60s as long
as 15 years ago you are one of the ones
that I remember the most is you played
Spock in the triumphs insult comic dog
that we're triumphs goes to the star
Star Wars movie line and you gave all of
these Star Wars fans the finger as Spock
do you want me to recreate that right
now thank you mind ya since memory and
yes we I'm constantly running into
actors who tell me who've gone on to
bigger and better things and they tell
me did you know that in 1994 1997 I did
a horribly embarrassing thing for you on
your show that you made me do did we
ever do anything like that to you
besides on your show yeah okay let's
hear it well there was one that was the
most emasculated man in the world
playing your then you were playing a
character called the most imagine
there's new characters and I was in the
most emasculated man in the world and I
had to go out and shoot a free throw
miss pull a toupee off of my head reveal
this crowning glory and then I had to
look to the camera and say I have a
two-inch penis
[Applause]
that was that I would always called my
family like I'm gonna be on Conan
tonight and sometimes he would go in
there you wouldn't make it you would
hate us we wouldn't get on TV I didn't
hate that you hated so many people it's
in a temper he's right a lot of hate
yeah but that was the one my family song
they're like you've chosen the right
profession yeah
you